has it really come to this night city
[Music]
used to be iron for hire still acts like
it
but the eddies are worth the risk trust
me
anymore intel check the attachment
waiting on your seat thanks
whoa
think fleas like you just get in for
free
you got vip rooms here you know for
private shindigs
reserved for the boston call i think he
could use a little more company
don't try to play me either i see
eddie's or your ass is walking
just chill all right here
sweet jesus you hear that do you hear
what they're playing
each to their own johnny
that's what peeps with bad taste always
say
don't know what he did to deserve what's
coming but his music taste is reason
enough to drop it
all good
music in here is god awful
yeah i like it
beat keeps me awake
you want to have a word with your boss
oh
you're out of luck
he doesn't really like the dog
i don't care if he likes to talk i asked
you if he's here
uh sure he's upstairs in the vip room
just don't expect a friendly welcome
[ __ ] you going vip air is for vip you're
the boss we're type bus knows a lot of
peeps
sure [ __ ] ain't tight with a single one
yeah but but
boss said to let nobody in want some
alone time so cut the act
turn around
technology
ah
what the who the [ __ ] are you
how'd you get in here quiet down or i'll
have to cut our convo short
oh i get it i've got a bounty on my head
have i
who hired you
milotech asukaga or was it that wanker
dino
sit down jack i'm extending the [ __ ]
courtesy here the fact that you're still
alive means i'm open to parley
polly foo go [ __ ] yourself chitchat's
for [ __ ] so let's get it over and
done with you versus me come on see you
win
say you put me out of commission you
think your problems will just vanish
into thin air
you crawled under a lot of people's skin
said so yourself
militech
they won't stop till your head falls at
their feet
so what i'm supposed to blow my [ __ ]
brains out
no
all you have to do is leave night city
i'll tell him you took lead between the
eyes and none will be the wiser you can
start over a brand new life
yeah
start with what
everything i got's here my club
staff my girls
and everyone who wants you dead
this isn't a multiple [ __ ] choice
you're living on borrowed time
[ __ ]
[ __ ] bleeding [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that a yes or a no
just piss off and tell him the job's
done
come on get away from me
got someone else to fall over
this way
i see
yes
oh
oh
god
y'all
dino needs a drink later be
goodnight and good luck
hello everyone welcome to red streams2
what you just saw was the first look at
gameplay from next-gen consoles of
cyberpunk 2077 and if you would like to
see some more you can head to our
youtube channel soon to to watch the
whole the whole gameplay from the next
gen consoles we will be talking to you
today about patch 1.5 and next gen
update yes finally
yeah
but before we get into it let's maybe
introduce ourselves so my name is alicia
i'm a community manager uh with me is
amelia who's a senior community manager
and she's gonna be playing the game for
us today hello everyone we also have
philip martinkowski our gameplay qa
hello my friends
and pavel the quest director yes so as
you know i'm just a random dude with
internet connection but i'm really
really
happy and excited to show you guys what
we have in store
yes and we have a lot of surprises
prepared so first of all we're gonna be
talking about about patch 1.5 that is
coming to all of the platforms that
cyberpunk is available at exactly
and it also brings the nextgen update
for ps5 and xbox series s and x as well
as a few free dlcs
on top of that just a few yes and we
will basically walk through those
yes uh so
majority of the fixes and upgrades and
features that you will see in this uh in
the stream are coming to all of the
available platforms
but the next gen upgrade obviously uh
concerns the next-gen platforms
anyway maybe we should just jump in and
show you the changes that we prepared
okay
let's go
yeah exactly so uh as you guys see like
we heard uh online
a lot of feedback regarding the perks
right and and everything surrounding
that so one of the works that we've been
doing to actually
completely redo it and rethink it and
and look back and think exactly like how
we can actually do it better and there's
a ton of stuff that changed yeah exactly
uh basically we completely reworked our
perk trees but the first thing you
should notice here is that all of
perk's point are unassigned
and player if you continue your your
playthrough
on this patch
you are able to uh redistribute them
once more because our changes were so
vast that we have to
get all parts back to the player
okay so when i load my save game
basically i need to go back and
redistribute okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly
and
basic idea behind our changes in trees
in perks were was to
rebalance the game the combat in game to
make it more fair
and
as well as get rid of some not that
useful perks we got for example this in
famous perk
uh about
preventing detection under water
so that was my favorite one i was always
using it so uh yeah unfortunately
unfortunately you were the only one
i was the only one that's using it okay
as always maybe you'll find a new
favorite
yeah so we scrub them and uh add some
new that we find more interesting okay
okay so so i expect like that i can now
basically make my like dildo build
really effective right that's basically
what you're going to tell me yes yes
we make sure that your build the build
will be uh effective as never before
okay so what other specific examples can
we can we show our viewers now
for example in uh cool perk trees
uh we've got
ninjutsu instead of stealth
and here here is the perk uh dagger
dealer
and it reintroduced our uh throwing
knife combat loop but we will elaborate
on this later
um and this uh in this tree we've got
this this perk about being detected
under underwater blah blah blah uh but
now you have uh looking sharp
perk that enhances throwing knives nice
looking sharp yeah yeah
uh okay check it out
and here we have cold blood perk tree as
you can see and this is a perk blood
swell
previously uh it gains only immunities
for the player like immunity for burning
poison etc and now now we gave you a new
ability to survive a final blow so if
you think about it
uh you can
build around that uh
different play style let's say we
encourage you to to play more aggressive
to to play fast not to use covers
um so it's it's opportunity to you to um
to play like that
oh i see so basically like now i can as
a player i can really like
try completely different play style so
to say right like yeah just
play in a different way basically with
these changes exactly and i gave you
only a few examples of our changes but
there's a lot a lot more there and i
encourage you to to check them try them
i mean definitely guys when you put up
the game after 1.5 remember to check out
the perks check out what we changed what
we what we
rebalanced and redistribute all your
perks because otherwise you can just
get one shot by a random npc
okay you were mentioning the throwing
knives and i think it's the time exactly
check it out in action so i'm going to
yeah
equip some of those
uh so basically uh we make sure that you
will no longer lose your knife once
drawn
okay so so how does it work exactly like
it works like a boomerang let's say
because once you throw a knife it gets
back to you and okay so it's like a
classic cyber knife i get it okay so so
this this little circle in the middle
shows us exactly it makes it to come
back it's a it's a cool down for uh
coming back and it's different
regardless of uh depending on uh rarity
of the night so
if you got
legendary knife it will come back uh
faster
yeah okay i had no idea okay this is
really awesome and this ui element
basically that is appearing now at the
center right after throwing the knife
yeah it shows you it shows you when i
need to get back but yeah it's a timer
basically right it's a timer yeah but
you can you can approach the knife you
throw and get it back so
it is this part that encourages you to
to play fast
uh i see so i don't have to like wait
for my knife to be back i can just
approach it and grab it right okay okay
okay really nice if you combine perks
from ninjutsu with cold blood you can do
it uh
without
harm basically
okay i think amelia found some more
dudes
yeah but actually we were speaking about
the the knife throwing but there are
also a lot of changes to uh to the
combat ai of npcs in general so would
you guys like to elaborate on that yeah
yeah there's a lot of changes that makes
uh ai in combat more
effective let's say
enemies react better to player actions
they uh find covers more effectively
they exit them if we are flanking them
so it's hard to show examples here on
our stream but if you try the game you
will feel that there is a lot of changes
in quality
yeah and i really want to like in this
point like just give a lot of credit to
our gameplay team because they did a ton
of small changes here to basically make
the npcs be more clever be more
effective during combat and we really
like encourage you to just give it a
shot try it out you know see what
actually now npcs can do and and you
know how fluid the combat feels now
okay sounds good and
i think those guys left some motorbike
bikes no uh nobody's here
we like yellow
yeah exactly yeah so uh here is a first
change
we've got nail dreams now in what in
every bike in the game you've got yeah
it's it's it's a it's a basically a
small addon so to say but how do you
actually cycle through that amelia how
did you like enable that so i pretty
much pressed uh elastic on the on the
controller but if you play on your
keyboard you pretty much just press e
and
they will be on
beautiful okay in cars it is for
toggling uh lights
and and on bikes you you you turn your
own rims on
yeah and it's like we can do something
more i see you've already wait i haven't
seen that before
it's it's time to
talk a little bit about driving model
because in 1.5 patch uh there is a lot
of changes
about uh driving model in our game yeah
we can see what amelia can do now yeah
so here you can see a reworked burnout
model that you
you can you can do it uh more easily and
you
have a little fun with uh burning out it
works and i can do it on the cars and
the motorcycles right yeah every changes
uh are about bikes and uh cars as well
so okay
you mentioned cars and i i have to
have to check it out
yeah
the driving model generally is more
predictable
the vehicles feel a little bit heavier
we
we make braking better we simulate abs
for example
[Music]
also there is a opportunity to perform
drifts when you take the corners
exactly and i feel like the the
suspension also feels better in the cars
right now in 1.5
exactly and suspension was added to the
traffic cars as well so you can observe
that they they're moving on
on the on the on the suspension
what i like the most
uh is that each model of car feels and
bike feels a little bit different
and
it's and it encouraged me to to try
different different models and find the
the the
ones i liked the most yeah someone
didn't like my car and just crushed it
this is definitely something for the
community to try out for themselves and
check out like which car would be their
favorite which would feel the best but
this there is one thing i noticed that
amelia actually
uh
called a lot of vehicles and they they
landed in different places so they don't
they don't crash at one at one place
right now anymore yeah i mean so
we know that it was a bug right like we
we know that it was a bug that needs
addressing and of course you know we
took care of it so finally it works
properly right now
but i'm also seeing more changes
actually right now when amelia's driving
yeah one of the first person
one of the major improvement is that his
visibility
in a first person perspective when we're
driving a car
so we
we we tweaked them and now you can see
the road in each model so you can enjoy
first-person view when driving and enjoy
these beautiful dashboards that are
exactly
yeah i remember i think the villa fort
was like particularly bad before yeah
like i couldn't see [ __ ] from the car i
also was like so low that i felt like my
ass is like brushing the asphalt
literally yeah so
uh some i'm glad that actually like i
can now you know enjoy it in in first
person because before it was kind of
challenging to drive in the first person
it was a pity because this car was a
reward from one of the mission
and and
now you can you can feel it in 100
percent and yeah and we can do the
burnout as we can see and do the donut
as well in the cars right oh i
definitely need to try it once once the
glass is left because this looks
freaking amazing i wouldn't be able to
do it in real life but here
maybe
you should you should try you should try
it's safer this way to not do it in real
life
maybe maybe one day
i mean you should i will show you later
if you talk to the dudes by my window
you know because people do exactly that
uh you know in warsaw so hey um
that unfortunately happens but we have
also done
more changes you know when it comes to
the crowds and traffic in general right
yes
we make the city more living let's say
that uh for example we introduced uh
aggressive crowds crowds
crowds that can react to your action
your aggressive action and here you can
see that uh one of the crowd starts
shooting at you because you point car uh
gun at the ground they they actually
agreed some some of the normal ulcers
yeah yeah thank you guys
it's a it's a pretty cool thing like
just it brings up a bit more reactivity
and life to the city the fact that like
some of the crowds some of the people
are actually armed and they may decide
to actually attack you at the moment
when you when they like threaten them in
some ways yeah and here you can see that
animation of running is more
more smooth let's say
uh crowds no running crowds no longer
on stream when you turn camera away yeah
like they don't disappear they don't
spawn basically when you like make a 360
basically this is what you use it was
amazing we could actually see them
running the other way from you once you
once once we went further than them
yeah yeah and and also uh we we
introduced changes in crowds but also in
traffic so uh we've got oh
okay so let's let's look at what happens
to the traffic then we call it panic
driving and
basically we do the same as
with kraus so so
drivers can react to players actions
they can run drive away
from the player who if you are
aggressive towards them
yeah
that's an example of just like simply
gang attacking us and following us yeah
yeah yeah
but um okay i need i need more cars guys
i need more cars exactly like so i think
we can showcase something else right
like our our psycho
oh you can't skip time because you're in
combat
yeah you need to get it let's go i'm
just gonna
kill this
you're accurate but basically what we
have introduced is like the fact that
right now when you cycle through the uh
to the time which i think amelia
actually can do right now yes is that uh
the the crowds will actually change here
you have one of our quality of life
improvements
yeah we we definitely redesigned the ui
of uh of the skip time mechanism so you
can now more clearly see which time you
will be skipping to
and you you don't have to do the math uh
which yes
which hour will be when you skip uh
six hour hours forward yeah so i see
that we skipped time to like the uh
middle of the day and now the streets
are actually more full than they were
during the night yeah crowds and traffic
is uh longer this bye bye just drove
over that guy
poor fella
yes so okay
i think this is phillip would you have
called just before a panic driving
correct yeah yeah exactly exactly
yeah you can see this guy exactly like
because we had started shooting he
decided [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm moving away
from here
i mean they tried but i can see that
they they even crashed a little bit
so
the drivers can crash into obstacles and
for example lose consciousness uh in
front of the wheel so yeah
the cars can crash into themselves the
crash can actually uh i think like drive
over pedestrians as well that also
happens uh yeah exactly oh yeah here you
have an example of like that uh driver
decided to
get the hell out of here
i think this guy is
oh yeah he probably lost consciousness
there yeah okay amelia do you think
maybe maybe we've had enough of like uh
mayhem in the middle of the city
did we
okay i think it's whoa oh that's one of
the examples actually when like during
the panic driving they can actually
drive on the pavement and drive on a
pavement when and of course you know
they can drive through the you know lamp
posts and all that stuff when they try
to get away from you
and you can also like i think what
philip uh mentioned that you can also
like follow them and basically see you
know what what those drivers do
okay so
but i see amelia has opened the map to
to like
find her way home and we actually have a
couple of changes on the map like some
new colors were added
yeah so there's actually lots of like uh
smaller quality improvements here that
contribute to this picture so first of
all of course you know the map in
general was refreshed the icons were
replaced now you actually very clearly
see the site content from the main
content
yes so the site content is now this uh
this greenish greenish hue and the main
main quest main gigs are still the
yellow ones so you can clearly clearly
see which ones are which
exactly basically the green color is is
from the fixers
yes
exactly
exactly and you can hear and you can see
here like basically undiscovered gigs or
just gigs this is basically boosting a
bit of a sense of a discovery for you as
a player okay what it is before you you
could basically kind of tell you know
what it is now before you actually
discover it you don't know but there is
actually more yeah speaking of fixtures
right now as we
we see now he has the counter of of the
gigs that he that can be completed for
him
and besides that we don't also get all
of the gigs at once from from the fixer
so we need to earn some standing by
completing some gigs for them before
they can give us more of those
exactly that basically in general it
contributes to this overall feeling of
me as a player like sv in a mercenary
night city actually progressing you know
uh when i'm actually like gaining the
street cred and gaining experience in
the city doing the gigs and whatnot i'm
gaining that standing as you can see
basically that reputation with a certain
fixer um
and basically more jobs more interesting
jobs actually unlock as you progress
but they also they also have a reward
for you once you complete all of the
gigs for specific fixer
right yes that's true actually so that
basically is an encouragement uh for you
as a player to actually try out there
are new rewards uh that we have added a
completely custom pretty cool uh rewards
that we have added for you uh to try out
basically so uh uh that a fixer will
basically contact you and you know you
will know what to do and how to get your
uh reward from there i guess we don't
have to spoil them yeah and it's also
worth mentioning that we added filters
to the map so you are no overwhelmed
with all icons at the same time you can
filter through them
yes and the filters were visible at the
left corner of the map just a moment ago
so you can like cycle through this and
basically see the um
see you know all the side content all
the uh you know activities coming so the
white icons basically so let's say you
know vendors reproducts or whatnot joy
toys obviously yeah
as well
yes so it definitely declutters them up
a lot so you can you can only see the
most important things that you are
looking for at the moment uh anyway as
we are heading to home uh maybe we
should we should somehow is it
yes
because we mentioned some of the changes
that are coming with 1.5 uh
the combat ai as well as crowd behavior
and drivers ai is getting smart smarter
it's getting uh it has more more diverse
reactions to what v does in night city
we also have driving model driving
models don't forget
of course that's very important
but also also now we have we have
working knife rowing which actually
brings the whole new playstyle to the
game we reworked a lot of perks and
changed some stuff in the perk trees
uh
i have to i have to mention one more
thing but not only combat is rebalance
but also economy in the game so you you
rewards are bigger you get more cash and
prices are also rebalanced so for
example vehicles are not that expensive
as in
1.3
so it's easier to easier to
buy stuff for example you you don't have
to choose between them right you can
finally get that achievement then yeah
exactly and why we talk about economy i
think wilson has something for us
because you know look at his stories
like oh bread
looks like cell looks like whips on sale
wilson wilson is having a first sale it
seems that the inflation has hit him
badly um so you can see here like a
bunch of new decorations of course you
know we have like updated that bit so um
what what we can actually expect from
wilson now well first of all let's let's
just say that this is actually the first
dlc that we are introducing in 1.5
because clearly clearly we are adding
some new stuff uh and the new stuff are
so pretty much i i sort of cheated
before the stream and i already visited
wilson i'm sorry
but i already bought like two new
weapons so it's the guillotine in umbra
uh but they come in like different
colors different varieties as you can
see uh but i think i think we can do a
little magic skip time again
so basically he he has two new rifles
with different appearance
uh we've got new scopes and
muzzle breaks that enhances uh ricochet
bullets
um handyman okay so so how does his shop
work because like i see that after
actually skipping this this time and
actually waiting a bit uh it seems that
his stock has changed right and we see
this like new label right on those icons
that basically communicate to the player
that this is a new stock but how
basically the the store works
this dlc
these dlc is enabled
at the beginning basically at the
beginning of the first act of the game
we have to meet takamura
at tom diners oh yeah don't leave him
hanging basically don't leave him please
not like in the mans
and after after this scene we get we are
informed by wilson
by text message that he has sailed and
we when we are approaching him for the
first time
he got most of the items from dlc
and and uh
when we visit him later on it will be
randomized so yeah and we can cheat that
as we see like amelia did by simply
skipping time so he has time to restock
uh on on the guns and on the new stuff
yeah oh okay oh so that's that's
guillotine
yeah okay that's pretty sweet
okay
i think that
i think that you know our players can
just like you know um
after getting the uh the update uh just
have fun with it and just check out we
don't have to showcase everything uh
because we like to leave some secrets oh
yeah definitely um
exactly
there are nice colors as well
so so you also can randomize them cheat
the time like skip the time and then you
will get all of the new colors like
collect them all right
yes
we're not that expensive either so you
can afford yeah as we are moving to the
through the um
mega blok i just wanted to mention
something like we have also done like
one of the bigger quality of life
improvements which is actually option to
reject holocaust
at the moment when
anyone from actually side content in the
game will call you right now as a player
you have an option to reject it before
it was not possible and in that case
actually this given npc will follow up
with you with a custom text message um
in case of actually bigger and more
important npcs those will be more
customized messages and so on i will
leave it for you uh to discover but it
was an important change for us to make
uh it is actually in settings that you
can by default reject some of the calls
like the police commissioner or
something and cpd dispatcher yes
actually
okay can i go home now yeah yeah
okay
grounded
it was a busy day
so what we have in the whole own home
then
well i think oh yeah that's something
that we definitely want to show you it's
being spoiled on the screen right now
so uh
not anymore basically what we added is
the ability to change your appearance
mid-game
exactly in in in the mirror in this
apartment so here we go
page appearance but how does it work so
is that is it just it right like is
there anything more uh to it oh yeah
definitely i mean i mean we have all the
options that were available to you uh
before like uh when it comes to hair
color or or makeup styles in the
character creator but we also added a
bunch of new uh new options for like
hair or makeup and stuff like that so as
you can see now we have a bunch of new
colors i think amelia is gonna choose
one of them because they're come on
they're beautiful yeah okay so just yet
exactly show us some some new ones so
this is this is one of the new ones
right like i don't remember yes yes only
one thing one thing do we have red
lipstick finally
i will see
yes we do that's another one that's
another one finally what's also cool
that you can actually choose the style
of your of your uh lipstick so it's
either either glossy or
matte
or mud definitely yeah um
i think glossy is also my choice yeah
and also also we have so many new
beautiful makeup options for your eyes
oh as you can see amelia is quickly
going through them but definitely you
guys need to check them out
and they're not only available here in
the mirror but you can also like if you
decide to create the new character from
from the start uh
then it's also available in character
creator at the beginning of the game
with an improved lighting as we can see
now it's much more natural
than it used to be
yes okay for sure okay i'm just going to
quickly go for hearts
that's beautiful
yeah we have also added like a small
touch like a more of like a narrative
touch here basically after changing it
you can see basically he looking at
herself in the mirror um you know just
give it more of a feel okay
let's uh
exactly okay
we need to we need you to show us your
your own like makeovers uh after after
you have the patch uh downloaded because
because
we're curious what we
i was talking to the viewers but yeah
philly
red lipstick red lipstick
exactly let's let's jump on it um okay
but it's so so that was basically a
second dlc as far as i'm aware right
like but that's not all right like we
also have the third one the third one
here
and the third one is a pretty pretty big
it's actually you know we've been
talking about this makeover and now we
go to home makeovers yes
exactly so we have added basically a new
website in your computer on this
apartment called easy estates and uh
here you have two different options as i
can see for rent and and making
renovations and makeovers
we're gonna we're gonna go for makeovers
first because our v just got make over
so i think the flat also
you know uh she like requires one yeah
to fit the theme and stuff and we have
six options you know amelia which one
would fit with the pink and i love her
the pink flamingo one
okay
okay so here basically after uh choosing
a certain makeover you can see basically
in large pictures so that you as a as a
player you can basically see okay does
it feel you know does it work for me um
can i express my masculinity fully uh
using this uh pink uh makeover you know
so here he can do it okay let's let's
see it in the
in the full glory
okay yeah let's let's look at it it's
definitely pink
and it's green but it cost us only 10k
so you owe me 10k
okay let's talk after the stream okay
right so as you can see basically like
the the whole apartment sort of gets a
pretty uh decent i would say repaint and
you have like as we said six styles
right
pick from cool so so whichever
represents you best you can pick one of
those
yeah but there's also more on the
website right
so let's go back
yeah let's go back and actually
basically this option this one
this option was for the players who
really love like the base v's apartment
in the mega blok
but in the mega building but there's
more
so we introduced four new apartments for
you to rent and each of them is located
in different place in night city so
basically whichever whichever fits you
best whichever uh whichever is
good for your pocket because uh as we
can obviously see the corpora one in
corporal plaza is is 55k so so it's a
lot more expensive than than the other
one in japan town for example which is i
think only 15k
yes and i'm gonna go for this one
because you took my 10k and i'm i cannot
afford corporate anymore
okay so when we were actually looking
into the design of the apartments for v
we thought about actually like uh for
the player be able to to be able to
express their own
identity as v so let's say you play as v
as a corporal right maybe you actually
really want that corporal plaza and just
really have that you know corporate life
or maybe when you play a street kid
maybe you would prefer the japan town
and so on i encourage you really to try
out you know different apartments and
see you know for what what works best
for you
okay but um
i already forgot where i have to go so
i'm gonna
check yeah so this is just one of the
small quality of life improvements that
we have introduced for you guys uh the
uh in the journal you have now the
apartment stub you can go there you see
all of those apartments with actually
nice uh flavor descriptions you can uh
basically track a certain quest you know
to get there
you don't have to use the website though
to uh rent the apartment you can
actually do it uh at the place you have
a separate scene you know that
introduces you into it again just a
small quality of life thing we didn't
want to force you you know to run to the
apartment and do that
yeah so either either by the website in
this apartment or you just you can just
stumble onto those apartments uh across
this the city
and it's worth adding that we've got
what this dlc is uh enabled
similar to the wilson sale dlc so after
after the beginning of the first act the
game after the kimura team okay so i
think we have a question from the chat
from mcbeefy
does nibbles follow you home to the new
apartment
no actually ebos doesn't uh and nibbles
does not follow you to the to the new
apartment and ibus is really a keen of
your uh apartment in the
um
in mega blok however nibbles also got
some new secrets to uncover uh because
this patch is actually packed with uh
things that we won't talk about uh and
uh things that are not even included um
anywhere uh and it's only for you to
find so um we made sure that there's
something uh for you to find regarding
this as well but i won't say anything
more so there are so i'm just saying
that uh he prepared something that
nobody knows about it even in the
company
i think only i think one person and one
qa knows what we did so it's like
probably three people
know about it so night city has some new
secrets to be discovered for you guys
right after the match
and now wait wait
no
no miles will kill us all because fast
travel
the time you know we we have to
fit all of that into into this short
stream but the next time we will be in
night city we will definitely take a
nice slow walk because
because you can do it
because you can
because you can because we added a walk
button work toggle to pc so basically
you can you can now just uh just walk
slowly and admire night city while doing
that
yes
in night city
yeah you can flex walking i mean but
it's not really like a huge feature or
anything but we know you guys wanted it
right like it was highly requested of
course you know we we have added it just
to be sure that you you you know you can
feel that we really listen um but then
we ended up in our new place
yes we ready
so let's let's go and let's see it
i'm gonna close my eyes i'm gonna close
my just just hit the thumbs up
right so first time when you actually
get to your apartment there's this small
video that will introduce you uh to it
um but then of course you know uh you
can move around and actually enjoy the
place so
i think here we can also mention uh work
that our environment art team has been
doing actually preparing those
apartments
okay so actually i can see that we have
another question from the chad
[Music]
and it's asking do you need to pay rent
for that or buy these apartments and the
answer is very simple this is a one-time
payment for the apartment so you rent it
rent it you pay it one time and it's
yours so corporal plaza you pay 55k once
and it's yours this japan town it's a
little bit cheaper just 15k and it's
yours so so it's it's pretty good price
i think
exactly
when amelia was like moving through the
flat we saw that there's a bunch of new
interactions uh that we have actually
added in the flat uh for youth for the
player for pretty much role playing so
let's uh check some of them okay
i'm gonna
do this
incense
yes so basically the interactions that
you have in those different departments
those are small things but they are all
basically contributing to you as a
player to the feeling of really
role-playing and being in a night city
and really enjoying it that's something
that a lot of players really asked for
and we felt uh that it was of course a
very reasonable uh request that's why
you know when working new apartments we
actually added it
now can we can also yeah let's play the
guitar because actually the chat is
demanding we play the guitar okay let's
play the guitar
and we have to call your mom
what song
oh my gosh the best one
the best the best one
it's a difficult choice
and here here you can see uh the design
design from 80s basically it's a
headless guitar
it's a close to the
design
yeah and i have here i have to
appreciate work from our animators and
cinematic artists
because uh i really like how they
how they make uh
moving uh fingers on a fretboard because
it's pretty accurate
uh right and left hand works really
really good really accurate so i this is
this is a small little touch but i like
it very much do you okay but what else
we have in the apartment right because
it was cool you know to sit down and
chill and and whatnot but i think there
is
more
oh yes yes yes
so while we are showing something more
we have another question uh whether you
can own all of the apartments at once
and
yes if you're if you're very [ __ ]
filthy rich yes
of course there's no limit you can
actually own all of the apartments so
feel free to do it
you need you just need enough addis to
that to do that
yeah so talking about those interactions
that we have added there's actually
more things that we've done right
because some of those actually give you
buffs yeah but maybe let's talk about
that one first i think someone was
asking about it we have the stash right
there on the right no
sure we can we can also really quickly
talk about the the stash so
basically apartments come in with the
stashes and here we have basically
introduced um uh another quality of life
improvement that uh all the stashes in
all the apartments are actually shared
so now as a player basically wherever
whichever apartment you have uh but
wherever weapon you you place you can
actually place it there and they all
actually show up on the wall we paid
attention to that because we thought
it's important a lot of players really
love to collect all those guns um on the
walls so here you can do it
also uh they are connected with stashes
in players vehicles so yes this is the
whole
whole web of stashes
it's all together okay now we can go to
sleep and showcase you that some of the
activities in the apartment actually
give us uh
buffs
yeah for example sleeping
give you about two experience points for
skills
[Music]
exactly there's yeah and there's bunch
more actually that we will we will just
leave the players to discover but
talking about sleeping right i need to
tell you about something so we know that
you guys are really loving the romances
right in our game and you're like really
liking the characters so we looked back
in our romances into our four romance
partners and we introduced a bunch of
new uh changes and improvements there
and one of the things that um
you can do right now is uh throughout
the development of the relationships
with those characters you can actually
message them way more often uh
throughout the whole development of that
romances and it's done differently for
each character we wanted to we paid
attention to the personality of a
certain character there's a bunch of new
things to discover there which i won't
talk about um i'm sure that someone will
eventually uh find it and encourage you
to talk to your partners but as you know
when you go when you become a partner
with someone that place of that uh that
person's place becomes a safe house
and that safe houses actually
got some improvements
okay so what what what happened there or
we don't want to spoil that maybe i
don't want to spoil it but one thing we
can mention maybe we can mention uh the
option to uh when you're going to sleep
uh you as a if you're a partner with
someone let's say judy uh there is a uh
chance uh i won't spoil how it's done
exactly but there's a chance that you
wake up next to your beloved person and
then there's more uh things actually
connected to this those are small
touches basically it's nothing really
major but those are small touches
throughout the whole storylines of those
characters that basically make you feel
really that you're closer to that
characters and also they they give you
like a proper uh sort of a continuation
to that romance story arc and i know
that a lot of you requested that i mean
and it's just in time for valentine's
day which was yesterday so
perfect timing okay uh yeah i need a
shower because i'm completely smashed
okay because i drank all my whiskey
i'm just gonna you know
walk in here
yeah so this is one of the one of the
one of the
fixes that we have done
yes which means v is actually taking her
clothes off in the shower right yeah
exactly so like that's the thing like i
remember i went to reddit like one at
one point and i was shocked to discover
that you guys shower undressed right
like that was that that was not really
uh you know something that came to my
mind right away but apparently most
people uh shower with no with no clothes
so we decided okay so we need to we need
to change it right don't tell me you
actually shower in your clothes
i i i do that randomly you know just
depends but anyway it was obviously it
was obviously an issue that we have
fixed yeah okay
but also i can see that the shower
shower actually gave us another buff
yeah exactly we can see the buff and
also i think amelia just passed next to
the mirror right amelia maybe we could
take a look at that because one thing i
wanted to mention is like aside of those
you know interactions that allow you to
role play a bit more and just really
feeling like being in a night city as a
player you also have the mirrors in all
of the apartments where you can actually
access the uh option to mod uh your own
appearance yeah so right now actually
johnny messed it up a little bit for us
yeah he says no
but in general all of the apartments
have the mirrors where you can customize
your character mid game
yeah johnny is here of course
intentionally right because like as his
uh a long time memory slowly leaking to
your short term memory and your
personalities are merging and what not
he basically starts to uh starts
appearing in the mirrors uh so that's of
course intentional that's that's not a
bug as uh i've seen sometimes people
claim uh that was of course intentional
and here in that case you know from time
to time johnny will appear and you could
see that amelia was actually able to um
get into the into the modding of the uh
of the face again and change the letter
okay but speaking of johnny uh we
actually went through like three
different dlcs which are the new guns
for the new apartments for v the new
uh new customizations to to this uh to
this uh look yeah
but we also added uh a dlc for johnny
and yes we did so so basically we added
a few a few new uh photo mode poses for
him so now whenever whenever you are in
the
uh in the scene uh in his memories when
you are playing as journey you can you
can take uh take opportunity and and
take some nice pictures with johnny
exactly and uh because we know that
they're like uh how to call it like at
the virtual photography scene for
cyberpunk is really huge like we
actually follow it kind of closely like
i personally love uh like watching it uh
watching fans creations and what you
guys can do and stuff um so uh
now you can actually do it with johnny
as well you don't have to mod everything
basically
yeah so those new poses will be
available in the flashback quest like i
mentioned where you are actually playing
as johnny and
come on guys show us what you got we're
really curious what you can create with
that
so guys uh i don't know i think i think
we were we were talking for for a very
long time about about those things and
this is not even everything that is
going in the patch 1.5 yeah it's just a
bunch of
the most important changes or changes
that we wanted to show
uh like the list is much longer actually
yeah okay
let's maybe sum up so we had a few dlcs
coming your way we have some extra
improvements and
pretty much now we can also see what
platform gets what right
yes so the dlcs are available for all
platforms most of the bug fixes
improvements rebalance stuff like that
also available on all possible platforms
there are a couple of uh of things that
uh won't be going to the last gen
platforms because because of the memory
issues mostly
but but
in general most of you will get the same
and here is a nice list of all of that
and this is going to be a pretty big
patch with all of that stuff it's going
to be around 50 gigabytes right it's a
chunky boy
boy
yeah so once the part is live uh most
platforms will just get an automatic
update and you will be able to to update
the game and just just start playing it
on the new patch there is one exception
though which is a playstation 5 because
the ps4 version that you are now
playing on your ps5 with backwards
compatibility
is actually a different version of the
game than the ps5 version which is
next-gen improved
so you're gonna have to go to your
library and download the ps5 version
manually
yeah and it's worth mentioning that you
have to move your save from playful on
ps4 version of the game to the ps5
exactly and then you can move only one
right like philip
yeah yeah
that's right and so
one more thing
we also on on ps5 we support dual
sensors uh
haptic feedback and adaptive triggers
and you you can try them when you are
driving cars
and
it's it's also supported in weapons when
you use them yeah it's also it's also
like supported in like a sex scenes uh
from what i remember because i
implemented it pavel implemented
this in every sex scene
personally
i implemented the joy toys
like so hey you were like the main qa
for this part right
designer qa
you're just running around with a dildo
implementing that intersection
i just i just have a lot of hobbies you
know this is how it's called but
speaking about dual sense there's
there's more right because there's also
a speaker yeah yeah so also also we use
speaker in the gamepad on ps5
so basically anything that is happening
in this head like getting uh phone calls
getting texts and stuff like that it
will be it the sound will be coming out
of out of the controller speaker so it's
like closer to you
yes exactly that
okay so what now what now now i think we
it's it's time to to talk about uh the
difference in modes on uh next-gen
platforms right
yeah that's the important point so we
have performance versus ray tracing our
gameplay was uh in the performance mode
am i correct yes
so basically you you can either choose
between performance when you you get 60
fps uh or ray tracing with the uh with
the rtx uh
enabled so basically whatever you feel
is more important for you when you are
playing the game uh you can choose the
correct mode to
uh to go to
easy as that
easy easy as that but we talked about
next-gen but we also have something uh i
think important for pc players uh
correct me if i'm wrong of course oh yes
uh we added something like benchmark so
pretty much if you want to you know
check how your your gpu your pc will
actually perform uh go to uh main
settings then press b as benchmark and
then you'll have
a section of like a few dynamic scenes
where the fps is pretty much like
constantly uh you know counted what you
know how it's going to be with rtx on
with rtxof uh with dlss on performance
balance quality whatever you prefer you
know
try them on find the best one for you
right now on the screen you can see that
this is
this benchmark is
actually recorded it come it comes from
uh nvidia
geforce rtx 3090 uh it's on 2k in with
the ss set on performance
so you can see the fps in the
top left corner uh it's going to be you
know you know 70 80 something something
around that on on this um
on the settings but like i mentioned you
know play with the settings
exactly and i think that that's the key
always you know to make the game uh work
best but amelia uh uh so that benchmark
is available for both yes for all gpus
out there exactly exactly and uh about
technical stuff uh one one thing more um
we support
amd fidelity fx super resolution now yes
finally i've got so many questions
all the time about this and i couldn't
say anything because i knew that we are
working on it and i wanted to tell you
but i couldn't but now i can yeah yeah
it's there it's there it's there it's
gonna be in the game
okay guys i think i think we are almost
there uh we talked about all the changes
all the dlcs the next gen features how
to download the patch event but the
question remaining is when to download
the part
yep exactly
i think we can watch it
yes let's watch it let's watch
downright refused to die anywhere else
170 people were killed in a cyber psycho
attack shots
listen kid
there's one thing i can tell you about
this city
you either love it
we want to burn it
no middle ground
coming here is a crash course in the
survival of the fittest
the greediest
the most vile
and most corrupted dogs see this badge
that means i can do whatever the [ __ ] i
want
but behind the blinding lights and all
the rot you might just discover a beauty
that can only be found here
night city is full of love
friendships
and family ties that run deeper than any
cyberware eddies can buy
zapper dumples and filth
in some ways night city never changes
your dreams live
not everyone's buying it
but if you want to know for sure you
just need to try it for yourself
yep
there are no mistakes there
exactly
the the patch the next gen update part
1.5 with all of this school stuff that
we've been talking about since 4 p.m
is now available for everyone on all of
the platforms so exactly guys no
bullshitting just go and download it and
check it yourself really yes and while
we talking about checking it out
yourself uh as you can see we also
released a free trial for all next gen
uh platform so playstation 5 series xbox
series s and x so if you still don't
have the game now is your chance to
actually you know go to the store uh per
platform and download it and try it
yourself you know if you if you actually
are
happy with night city and if you like it
uh yeah and what's important well uh if
you
try the trial and then decide okay i
liked it i want to buy the game you can
actually transfer your save to the full
game so the five hours they won't be
wasted you don't lose anything it's it's
coming back you can continue playing on
the same save yes from like i know that
like some of our players will probably
prove us that you know you can even
finish the game in five hours
but i mean you know that's fair if you
guys can do it just go for it really
like check it out yourself try it out
you know love it or burn it really like
see you know what cyberpunk is
yes totally but like from like technical
point of view as well it's worth
mentioning uh the trial will be
available for you for 30 days like we
mentioned five hours and it's going to
be available for free
as
the patch patch is also free for you yes
right now
so
this is everything basically if you are
if you want to go and download the game
right now the patch 1.5 you can you can
just do it because it's already live and
in the meantime if you are looking to
get real into all of the changes that we
that that we introduced in the patch
which we weren't able to tell you about
all of them in the stream uh the patch
notes are now available on cyberpunk.net
so you can you can go and read them all
yes
that being said like during this stream
we have mostly focused on like
improvements and add-ons and like new
stuff or or things that you guys have
requested or like some bigger bugs let's
say but there was actually a ton of bug
fix that lots of the pro departments
have been working on for past months
and that is nowhere to be found on the
patch notes you won't find it there you
actually only experience it in the game
we didn't want to like stuff the patch
notes with like thousands of entries
because that was pointless we only focus
on the most important uh things for you
so really the only way to experience
that is to get the free trial or really
put the game uh and check it out
so i think our job here is done you guys
just go download the patch check out the
patch notes and enjoy night city hope
you're gonna love it have fun everyone
and i'll see you around
yeah thank you guys so much i hope we'll
see each other in night city
[Music]
to
bye